[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui j'ai un texte monteur et en comic
sans ms c'était dégueulasse
bonsoir à tous bonsoir à tout
je suis très honoré de participer à
cette conférence ted aujourd'hui sur un
sujet qui m'est cher la déconnexion
d'autant plus honoré d'ailleurs que
beaucoup d'experts avaient éminent
briand se sont succédé devant moi sur
cette scène
j'ai assisté à des exposés passionnant
et pourtant pourtant je dois bien vous
le dire ce soir je ressens comme un
manque
j'ai la sensation qu'on a fait
qu'effleurer le sujet alors je vais me
permettre si vous voulez bien ce soir de
combler ce manque et de tenter une revue
de tout ce que nous aurions pu dire sur
la déconnexion
je vais tout d'abord commencé en vous
parlant d'une connexion terrible cette
connexion elle a fait souffrir
l'humanité toute entière mais elle m'a
fait souffrir
à titre personnel à bien y réfléchir
cette connexion n'était pas fait pour
notre espèce
combien de cris de rage de frustration
elle a pu engendrer particulièrement
pour les gens de ma génération plus que
pour les plus jeunes d'entre vous je
veux bien entendu parler de la prise
péritel la prise péritel un branchable
cet objet du diable avait pour fonction
il ya encore quelques années je cite en
sortant de la lumière une connexion
simplifiée des appareils qui exploite
des signaux audio et vidéo analogiques
au moyen d'un connecteur inventé une
broche
pouvait compter vingt-et-une broche
c'est ce à quoi a droit normalement un
cycliste qui se serait péter la gueule à
90 km/heure dans une planque du galibier
et qui se serait fait rouler dessus par
l'intégralité des camions publicitaires
de la caravane du tour de france
branchée une prise péritel et c'était
encore plus périlleux que d'aller se
faire épiler le sillon interface si un
jour de gastro vous connaissez le
l'inventeur de la prise péritel
connais tu m'étonnes le mec s'est barré
dans une hacienda en uruguay et ses
planques et avec les anciens dignitaires
nazis et james mason sims c'est
l'inventeur du spéculum lorsque oui les
filles comprendront les mecs un peu
moins lorsque lorsque l'on branché la
prise péritel il y avait un certain
nombre de problématiques qui ne s'est
pas cantonné des heures pour essayer de
brancher cette prise là loin très loin
derrière ses gros cul de tubes
cathodiques n'a pas vécu c'était une
sorte de mélange de sport de d'endurance
est un sport d'adressé comme le biathlon
mais sans le guen donc c'était vraiment
juste complètement chiens ont branché
je me souviens la console de jeux sur
notre télévision grâce à ce câble
péritel et quand avait réussi à brancher
un câble péritel presque fini le jeu en
fait
chez ma grand mère il n'y avait que la
console pourra pour se distraire ça et
changer les couches de mon grand père on
va pas se mentir quand à quant à changer
une couche sur tout un peu changé c'est
comme ouvrir plein de kinder surprise à
la suite avec toujours le même cadeau à
l'intérieur sauf que dans le cas de mon
grand-père le chocolat était dedans
bon je vais pas épiloguer là-dessus
comme vous le savez les les ted xtal qui
sont des conférences extrêmement charte
est extrêmement contrôlée par les
organisateurs pour preuve moi ils m'ont
fait signer un contrat m'interdisant de
prononcer les mots [ __ ]
q voldemort alexandre et benali
donc on va parler d'autre chose j'ai pas
coupé a long way je peux pas parler je
suis en chine
maintenant c'est une blague voyons je
suis pas connecté à ce point vous
rigolez ça se fait pas décroché en plein
territoire
donc on va parler de quoi on va parler
d'eux et bien de ce mot connectés
j'ai constaté que personne ne l'avait
vraiment identifié déterminer
durant toute cette belle journée alors
on va s'y affairent connecter à cet
amour qui aurait été une connotation
plutôt très positive avant que les les
objets numériques nous envahissent notre
quotidien on se connecter à la nature on
se connecter à nos émotions
oui on se connecter à l'autre on faisait
un petit peu comme dans avatar vous
savez jake sully qui se voit lui il se
connecte à tous simon multiprise il se
connecte indistinctement avec la même
connectique pour pour chevaucher son
dragon et puis pour faire l'amour à sa
copine sans changer l'ambiance est parti
et plus tard bien plus tard le mot
connectés a revêtu une connotation
plutôt négative pourquoi et bien parce
que on est devenus dépendants de ces
objets connectés
on était bien vite loin de ce fameux
rêve
nokia connecting people il faut bien le
dire les smartphones ils ont surtout
réussi à nous connecter aux gens qui
étaient très loin de nous mais ils ont
beaucoup déconnecter les gens qui
étaient très proches les uns des autres
j'ai pas si vous vous rappelez de
pokémon go qu'est ce qui s'est passé
avec pokémon ghosn
sans blague je les voyais c'était un
deux trois ans les gars étaient sur leur
smartphone comme ça il marchait comme
des zombies dans la rue alors oui ça a
marché
je me suis allé médias était très
content de dire oui pokémon go c'est
formidable les geeks sortent de leurs
chambres les normes se mettent à la
marche à pied légaré puisse faire violer
il aurait rien senti dionne eu deux
heures après ils ont effet tel un peu
mal au cul ça va être la marche à pied
de coin mais nous n'allons pas parler
que de pipi caca prout ce soir je vous
rassure un peu de culture ne fera pas de
mal session étymologie pour bien définir
ce qu'est la connexion le mot connectés
connectée du latin connectés ray si ma
mémoire est bonne oui c'est exact
connectez ray qui signifie liés ensemble
attaché joindre enchaîné ligoté bondage
passé
on dit merci qui ont surgi
composé de cons kohn bien prononcé avec
et nectars et le noeud nexus est
maintenant que j'y pense c'est plutôt
intéressant de voir qu'on est ne réunit
dans un même mot non genre et ça donne
de l'espoir pour l'égalité salariale
pour ceux qui voudraient aller un petit
peu plus loin sur cette définition de
nectar et sachez que ça n'a rien à voir
avec le saint nectaire
voilà là dessus vous êtes bien
nous avons également un autre moyen de
parfaire notre connaissance pour avoir
un véritable tour d'horizon de ce que
c'est que cette connexion c'est le
prisme légal saviez vous qu'il existe un
droit à la déconnexion
ouais depuis le 1er janvier 2017 est
entrée en vigueur la loi travail elle
comme rim qui disposent ceux ci un
travailleur salarié a le droit de
déconnecter il a le droit de ne pas être
contactées par son travail lorsqu'il est
en week-end c'était un peu chiant mais
j'ai l'impression d'avoir apporté ma
petite pierre à l'édifice de cette belle
journée
enfin journée j'en ai c'est quand on
voit le jour moi j'ai engrangé plus de
connaissances que vitamine d aujourd'hui
mais c'était un petit peu prévu puisque
je suis censé conclure et conclure ce
n'est pas facile sur un tel taux puisse
comme ceci parce que ça oblige à revêtir
le costume un peu lourd du tonton un peu
bourré en fin de soirée
un mariage qui va lancer une chenille
pour détendre l'atmosphère
là où quelques heures plus tôt un
bellâtre encore agen un témoin de
mariage avec le cheveux disciplinés avec
l'assistance de son discours aux mariés
verbeux élégant toujours très énervant
cela on reconnaît tout 5 et 6 tombe
souvent il a fait le aimerions centrale
au choix puis jet lag en deux saisons
parle trois langues bien et pour moi
cette secte vous cette thématique de la
connexion est assez importante c'est
pour ça que je voulais pas non plus la
bâcler je voulais parler de choses
essentielles et si on m'avait demandé
mon avis j'aurais plutôt parler que
d'eux des connexions je veux parler de
reconnexion reconnexion à la nature j'ai
constaté il ya quelques temps que nombre
de mes connaissances ne s'étonnait pas
d'entendre dans les airs des parcs et
jardins parisiens dès ce cri strident
c'est le chant d'abord j'avais loupé
celle-là de la perruche à collier la
perruche à collier qui est toute mimi
avec son petit bec rouge et sa belle son
beau plumage vert qui est une espèce
invasive au même titre que le frelon
asiatique
cette espèce n'a absolument rien à faire
chez nous les premiers spécimens se sont
échappés de cargaisons aux aéroports de
roissy et d'orly il ya quelques années
et aux colonisés par milliers
l'ile-de-france où
elles sont plus maintenir il faut bien
le dire sous nos latitudes grâce au
réchauffement climatique
ne nous leurrons pas elles sont belles
mais elles sont nuisibles à l'instar du
réchauffement climatique qui nous permet
joyeusement de siroter l'apéro plein
mois de février en terrasse ces oiseaux
n'ont rien à faire là et ils sont
dangereux
j'insiste là dessus parce que se
reconnecter c'est aussi percevoir dans
notre environnement les choses qui ne
vont pas les bruits d'oiseaux exotiques
par chez nous mais également percevoir
ce silence géant qu'on peut avoir dans
nos forêts constater cette perte de
biodiversité qui entame nos littoraux
nos rivières dans les airs les rivières
tout disparaît la nature s'étiole meurt
sous nos yeux parce qu'il faut bien le
dire on a fait n'importe quoi alors je
suis pas là pour révolutionner votre
vision de la connexion de la déconnexion
j'ai aucune légitimité pour faire ça je
pas expert gerin jarnac elle mention
rattrapage donc je ne vais pas vous
parler de ça moi mon métier c'est de
faire de la sensibilisation auprès de
ceux qui n'en sont encore encore
convaincu à l'environnement et il est
vrai que je parle souvent d'écologie
conférence comme je le fais aujourd'hui
mais aussi sur le web dans des livres à
la télé à la radio partout me demande et
à force d'en parler à force de côtoyer
des gens qui partagent cette même
angoisse eh bien il faut bien le dire je
commence à avoir peur et
ma petite vie de militant militants est
un trou béant de cette peur qui
envahissent mon foyer ma vie familiale
parfois mon sommeil de temps en temps
j'essaye de ne pas y penser
j'essaie d'oublier en faisant quelques
blagues on sensibilise à l'humour et au
maître de vous en parler un peu ce soir
c'était ma façon à moi de déconnecter
merci de m'avoir écouté
[Applaudissements]